[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and in your relationships the phone
number to jump in is
8825 5225 asle 8 825
5225 I'm Ken Coleman joined by George
camel we're Ramsey personalities and we
are your guides this hour George will
help you out on the money questions I'll
weigh in I'll take any work related
questions you're feeling stuck but
you're in the baby steps can I move do I
start a side hustle what do I do to
bring in more income think of me as just
the bigger shovel guy shall we say that
George and what does that make me well
chop liver no you're the financial Guru
you're the guy I don't know that anyone
I don't want to be anyone's Guru but I
see where you're going with this all
right the point is people are going okay
they're new to the show okay where's
Dave money and work money and work and
uh that's what we're going to do today
we're going to help you out there so
let's get started Heather is waiting for
us in Oklahoma City Oklahoma Heather how
can we help hi um okay so my question is
my husband and I are currently on baby
step two and so approx a little over
$700 a month is going towards our debt
payment so once we get done with baby
step two and then also have our fully
Fundy emergency fund then we'll the next
step is doing 15% towards retirement but
50% towards retirement is like over $800
a month
um so part of how I got my husband on
board with this was telling him like oh
look this is an extra $700 we're going
to have per month once all of this is
paid off but actually now that's just
going to be going towards retirement so
if we can barely afford our debt payment
how are we going to be able to afford to
put even more than that toward
retirement well I would take a good hard
look at this budget and go where where
are these money leaks happening because
sometimes it's an income problem and
that's where our friend Ken Coleman
comes in handy to go let's increase the
income because truthfully 15% even
without debt for some people is going
it's going it's too tight now if you've
got a dollar for every name and you're
still accomplishing all your financial
goals it's okay it's good to have a
zerob based budget where every dollar
has an assignment and there's not you
know a thousand extra dollars of fund
money sitting around but if you're
telling me that just paying your normal
bills and investing 15% creates zero
extra margin for let's say saving for
college or paying off the house early
that tells me we might have an income
problem M which one is it for you or you
think you have some expenses that are
also hanging out or is it
both um it's Pro I mean it I I don't
think it's much expenses I mean I I
don't use your guys' budgeting program
but I do use um the YNAB you need a
budget program and so um I'm very aware
of our expens expenses and and all of
that and everything gets a job and is
accounted for um it could be an income
problem um but I'm not really sure how
we can make more money like my husband
works 50 to 60 hours a week um what's he
make doing
that um about 60,000 a year what is he
doing he works for a dairy processing
plant doing
what um just like running the line and
loading the trucks and things like that
okay so would you call what would you
call that is that like a
manufacturing I guess a manufacturing
milk yeah okay and uh how long has you
been doing
that um almost 12 years okay and then
tell us about your what's your salary
and what are you
doing I'm working part-time from home
doing data entry um and one of the
reasons why and so the reason I need
something flexible like that is because
we have five children five young
children and two of them are special
needs and so like I need to be able to
take them to their appointments and
things like that okay so and your
husband's working did you say 50 to 60
hours a week yes wow and so he makes
like I think $22 an hour and then
anything above 40 hours is
overtime um and then he's even like
ubering some nights after he gets off
work there's days that like I don't even
see him oh okay is there room for growth
in this field where he can be making 253
$35 an hour in your
area working in maybe
management the management is salary and
he has said he doesn't want to do salary
because then they can just have you
there all the time um more than 60
hours he's already there all the time so
if he can be there 60 hours and make 80
or 100 I would rather that is he not in
I don't know how much more the the
managers make um well here's why
question if I were sitting with him
today I would say Okay based on your
skill and your experience
what is transferable out of that
industry that he's in or specifically
that type of company um where he could I
mean he's got my guess is he's got a lot
of skill and a lot of experience that
would be transferable to where he could
be making 75
$80,000 what does the path look like to
that now that may take some time but it
may not and I think many times it's very
intimidating for somebody in his shoes
he's been doing this for 10 years and he
wonders am I limited is it scary to look
out but it doesn't it doesn't require
him to take a risk to look to talk I
would at least start looking and start
talking to see what's out there because
it is possible I believe on the surface
Heather for your husband to be getting a
nice boost right now and that would be a
GameChanger based on what you and George
figured out we got to get some more
income but not the kind of income that's
back breaking like uber he's already
working crazy hours and there's just not
a great return on time with a with a
role like uber in your situation in your
area that's my guess is that
correct yeah I mean he may maybe 101 to
$20 an hour maybe like 20 is at best
yeah that's an hour Uber what are you
bringing in with your part-time
work um $25 an hour 15 hours a week so
you're making more money than he is
that's right on an hourly basis yeah I
think that's our room for growth I think
he treats us like a full-time job I
really do I think I would do less Uber
over the next two or three four weeks
and I would spend that time connecting
with people coffees talking to people
going hey I'm looking to kind of to to
level up and uh I just think he needs to
be making well more than 60,000 and I
think he can I think there's a path to
that what's your mortgage
payment uh 1,200 okay so it's fairly
reasonable considering the income but I
still think you know with five kids
you're just going to have more expenses
and there's going to be less to put away
for college and so that's why the only
way here if you've already cut down all
the expenses you can it doesn't sound
like you guys are living super luxurious
frivolous Lifestyles here and so the
only other option is we got to make more
if we can't spend any
less yeah you guys should be able to do
that with you making 25 an hour 15 hours
a week plus his 60 there's got to be
some room here so I'm going to take a
second look at the budget do a little
budget audit and see can we do any
better can we reshop our insurance
through Xander because we might save 200
bucks a month just like that M so you
can do all kinds of things are you
getting a tax refund every year maybe we
should you know increase our tax
withholding or decrease it depending on
the situation in order to have more cash
flow every month yep but I I will tell
you Heather I mean I I wish I could take
your husband on full-time I believe we
could get him into a
$80,000 with a path to six figures
that's what we've got to be thinking
about here's what we're going to do I'm
going to give you the get clear career
assessment Hang On the Line This is a
wonderful tool it's my gift taking about
15 to 20 minutes max it's going to spit
out a purpose statement which is
essentially a job description showing
him what he does best what he loves to
do most and what results motivate him
and I think it's going to show him some
things he's not seen before I also give
you the book from paycheck to purpose
which is like the guide up the top of
the mountain that the assessment points
out both of those products comeing your
way early Christmas president want to
see him dream and then put some steps
towards doing what it takes to get a
sizable pay raise which changes your
life you guys are good people you're
going to win hang in there don't move
more Ramsey Show and your calls coming
up
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me we're your
guides this hour we're here to help you
win we're going to give you some hopef
filled practical advice to help you win
with your money your work
and your relationshipss George is our
money Guru and I'm going to help you out
in the area of work so you're making
more money George is going to help you
keep more money so we're happy to take
any of those calls we got a new year
coming up George so people are thinking
about do I stay do I go uh you know as
it relates to making a career move so
hey we'll talk to you about any of that
stuff we're going to start it off with
Nathan in Sacramento California Nathan
how can we
help hi um well my wife and I we have
had some money discussions recently
because I was living check to check we
were living Check to Check and um I
recently lost my job oh no what
happened um well it's a company that was
going through some changes and uh within
the technology technology industry where
I've had a lot of experience there have
been a lot of changes lately so yeah I
was one of those those changes well uh
you know listen you're not alone uh
Spotify just announced massive layoffs
today interestingly enough so that
happens in tech companies they staff up
then they staff down and um I just want
to acknowledge something uh Nathan that
we know from psychology research that
when someone loses a job either laid off
or fired that it has the same emotional
effect of losing a loved one so you know
it that's a tough thing and I want to
acknowledge that and I've been fired and
I've been laid off so welcome the club
head up um you're going to be okay what
kind of work was it specifically in
technology I was the head of a
recruiting department really okay so
more on the HR side of things yep yeah
we would hire engineers and everyone
else you would need for software
companies okay so you know this you you
you know what's going on you have a good
idea of the landscape is that true
absolutely y I've been doing it for
about 15 years what's great is your
skills are very transferable to any
company that does HR and recruiting
which is every company so I I believe
you're going to bounce back quickly but
let's talk about where you're at right
now how are you guys keeping the lights
on is there other income is there a
severance uh so I did receive a
severance and that's also why I'm
calling uh we do have quite a lot of
debt and we are trying to figure out
what we should prioritize here over the
next couple months um when it comes to
the industry a lot of my colleagues have
had changes over the last several months
and my concern is how quickly I can
actually get back up on my feet and so
um my wife and I are having a discussion
as to whether we would want to save the
money or to use that to to pay off debt
and um we're trying to figure out if we
should wait or pay things off now and
then in what order we should do that
well you know I'm a big fan of debt
payoff but this is one of those times
where we would call this storm mode
where you want to just pause and stack
up as much cash as possible to weather
this storm before we go make any
Financial moves and that includes paying
off
debt okay so the goal right now is let's
maintain let's keep the lights on food
utilities shelter Transportation that's
your A1 if nothing else gets paid those
get paid and then minimum payments on
all of your debt until we can figure
this out figure out what the next step
is is your wife working outside the home
no she's not I've made a commitment to
provide for the family and she's uh
taking care of our son okay how old is
the son he is uh going to be 12 in a
couple weeks here
12 yes Hey listen I I'm going to jump in
real fast just as George said there are
times where we kind of deal with the
snowball I think there are times where
we have to maybe be flexible with some
principles and commitments and I love
the fact that you said I've made a
commitment that my wife worked from home
she got a 12-year-old not a 12-week old
not a 12-month-old and maybe for a
season she's working at least part-time
maybe she's working full-time I think
this is a real discussion and I think I
I I would not be authentic to what I
believe if I didn't jump in and tell you
that I'm just going to leave that there
not trying to convince you but I think
for season maybe we need to consider her
going back to
work thank you I appreciate that advice
so what's your plan currently let's say
you don't get land an HR job for the
next three months are you going to just
burn through the
severance that's not the plan for me
right now I am working every day looking
to for a new opportunity and I'm also
basically starting my own business so uh
putting up a shingle and reaching out to
contacts for either work and or um
offering my services so um like HR
Consulting or what HR Consulting
recruiting Consulting I've also had to
run some HR layoffs recently as well and
so I've been on both sides of the table
and um unfortunately there are a lot of
reorganizations going so I can help with
that as well so on top of you know
hitting up your LinkedIn crew
unfortunately that doesn't pay the bills
so we need to do something that is
actually creating an income right now
even if that's working retail and that
might mean swallowing our pride and
going I'm going to do whatever it takes
to make that 20 25 bucks an
to keep the lights on this
month okay so what's the sance how much
do you guys have in the bank right now
yep so the severance is two months worth
of pay um and it's going to be gone in
two months so um and you have no savings
exact amount the savings is very minimal
um I have my 401k but I don't want to
really cash that one out that out right
now okay so yeah give give us a number
how much money are you going to have in
the bank yep we have 30,000 right now
and that will only get you buy for two
months $155,000 or monthly expenses
how uh we have a lot of debt and um we I
was making a lot of money so you guys
have a car you can
sell we do actually that's on our list I
think that needs to get sold today this
is I mean how much money were you making
I was making $190,000 a year and What's
the total debt
load uh we have a mortgage that is at uh
$480,000 with the second at$ 80,000 and
then we have about $660,000 in credit
cards and about $660,000 in loans and
the car loans
60,000 the car loan is separate that is
at 30k what's the other 60k in loans you
said after the credit cards um those
were debt consolidation loans so credit
card consolidation loans and then we we
dumb and ran up the cards again man you
guys wake make way too much money to be
this broke this is a a sad wakeup call I
wish you didn't have to land this way
with the layoff but I hope this is your
I've had at moment where you guys start
looking at these numbers and you're
scared and that's a good thing because
it means you're never going to be in
this position again and that means doing
hard things like selling the car cuz we
were living Lita Loca living this fake
lifestyle uh that we couldn't keep up
with and life happened and we had a
stay-at-home spouse and that adds you
know the consequence of that is it adds
risk if you lose one income you lose all
the
income so I think we have to make some
uh more sacrificial changes and we're
going to start with selling the cars and
getting beaters to get by for now and
I'm now going to say I think the wife
needs to work full-time the 12-year-old
can let himself in after school is the
12-year-old in school right now
full-time he is he is and he can let
himself in yes hey man let me tell you
something I hope you're receiving this
the with the right Spirit but it's time
for her to work I mean it doesn't have
to be forever but that is a game changer
maybe 3 months from now you're back to
making 200k but even then you guys have
a giant pile of debt to clean up so
maybe she works until we're totally Dead
free
100% cuz living in that area you know
the Bay Area is where you're at
Sacramento where you at pretty close
pretty close I can drive to the Bay air
today so so life ain't getting any
cheaper out there and so this is a scary
moment where you go are we going to have
to
move if we can't sustain this lifestyle
out here you know that's a tough spot to
be in so I would just have some hard
conversations with your wife and say
honey you know I wanted you to be able
to stay home full-time forever right now
here's the sacrifices we're going to
have to make we have to sell the cars
you're going to go back to work for a
little bit and I'm going to work my
hardest to get a land that job again to
where we can get some stability in place
yep okay you got it Nathan there are
your marching orders I mean this is
doable I mean it's not impossible but I
can't stress this enough I was on
Wharton uh business radio this morning
and a guy asked me the host said what
would you say to people who've been laid
off and the first thing I'd say is is
that you got to heal you got to have a
day or two of just kind of cry it out
cry it out hang around friends and
family get all the support necessary but
you're getting back to some type of work
immediately don't don't sit the best
thing to kind of recovering from this
emotionally is getting busy keeping some
income coming in because the worst thing
can happen after getting laid off or
fired is to feel the financial pinch
that that makes everything else worse
George yeah well you know what Ken this
is going to be for our friend Nathan
it's going to be a comma not a coma and
he has to remember that don't get stuck
you're going to move on man you'll get
there get busy keep bringing money in do
whatever it takes and then it's going to
get better all right good stuff thanks
for the call Nathan we're cheering for
you here East George camel I'm Ken
Coleman you're listening to the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
default Ed private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom ref financing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me we're here
for you this hour the phone number is
88255 2258 8255 225 George I was with
Rachel on Friday and at one point uh
coming back from the break I mentioned
that it was a toll-free number and she
made fun of me and now I'm getting hit
on Instagram you might as well mention
hey go to your nearest pay phone and
give us a ring yeah some guy in
Instagram was like oh yeah yeah from the
pay phone the toll-free number from your
home phone all of the things so got to
work on the old man references here I
like that you remind us of of what a
different time we live in I think that's
how you I think that's what I'm witting
unwittingly doing that's the sad part
but we're still helping people no matter
if it's toll free or not to your credit
there is no toll it's a free show which
is amazing I know I'm just trying to
keep the young kids attached uh let's go
to Hayden who's in laning Michigan
Hayden how can we help hey guys um first
off you I wish you understood the impact
you've had on my house in the last 12
months you have flipped the place upside
down and that's the reason for my call
wow um my wife and I have been married
for two years now um brought a little
baby girl in in the spring and before
that we have kept our money separate she
had her account I had mine she paid
these bills I paid these well in the
last 90 days we've knocked our heads
together enough that we're ready to
merge everything together and we're just
looking for some guidance um we're in
baby step 2 um over the last 6 months
we've cleared out probably 40 Grand we
got another 30 or 40 to go before we
start getting crazy with the house um we
were your typical middle class Americans
we had 0% this and 0% that and credit
card here and uh that's all stopped we
did some plastic surgery and uh we're on
a better path because of you guys I
walked away from a 10year career um
thanks to you John and not entirely
because of you you gave me the courage
to do it but um it's been a whirlwind of
12 months and we want to just keep doing
the right thing and and merge our
finances the right way cool well I'm
glad you called sounds like you're ready
for some more life change you guys have
already been at it but you're saying
we're ready to fully combine what does
that
mean so she has a checking and the
savings I have a checking the savings
she pays some of the smaller bills she's
a stay-at-home mom with a side business
that keeps her busy I'm a full-time
sales guy making anywhere from 100 to
150 a year so I pay the mortgage you
know the big stuff she kind kind of
takes the little stuff but I hate that I
don't want to do that anymore um is it
as simple as just open a savings in a
checking put both our names on it and
push everything in one bucket you know
should she have her account for play
money I have mine for play money it's
this simple you can actually make your
account into a joint account so you
don't even have to go make a new account
you just go to the bank and say hello
we'd like to make this a joint account
instead of just mine and then she can
shut her accounts down and you guys just
use one checking and one savings and
that's it that's that's exactly what we
did last week the only hang up there we
have her car that we're both paying on
very quickly to make it go away that's
on her account so we can't kill hers yet
uh because we got to pay that car off
because we don't want to refy it we got
a great interest rate at what it is
where does it get paid
from uh she takes her side business
money and that is her sole bill today I
have taken over pretty much confused
can't you just pay that car loan from
this other bank account starting
tomorrow uh we could yes but you can't
close the account I'm not asking to
close the The Loan account but you're
saying it's tied to that bank
account it is T yeah I guess like well I
don't know I don't I think you can just
pay that loan from this different
checking account it's not tied to the
checking account I think you're correct
so I don't think there's any excuses
left I mean you guys are done living
like roommates combine it all and you
asked about what about his his money and
my her money just in a in your budget
there's a line item for Hayden's fund
money and that gets spent from the same
checking account and when your money
runs out it's out and so if anything
it's going to create more accountability
as you guys get on that budget together
it sounds like you haven't been making
one budget using every dollar for
example we just downloaded every dollar
we just dug into it we laid everything
out what comes out every month when it
does so we're probably halfway through a
budget I would say okay I'm going to
hook you up with every dollar premium
that will actually connect to your bank
account which is going to make this
whole process a whole lot easier would
you use it if I gifted it to you without
a doubt okay wonderful hang on the line
we're going to gift to you one year of
every dollar you guys are going to get
together on a weekly basis right now and
just take a look at the budget and
before the month begins you're going to
make a new budget and go what's coming
up this month and that level of
communication and Alignment is going to
take out all the money fights and it's
going to take away all the stress of
button heads and whose money is this and
it's not her car loan you have a car
loan my friend and so the sooner you
guys get aligned on that the sooner
you're going to make progress even more
than you have uh recently so I'm proud
of you guys that's a big step Ken it's a
big paradigm shift to make for couples
out there who are so used to well this
is my money and well that's her money CU
she stays she's got her little business
let her have that money yeah I don't
subscribe to that I think anybody out
there that's been married for any amount
of time knows that money can cause a lot
of stress issues you've probably seen
the data about how it's probably the
number one issue of stress in a marriage
and and and and one of the things that
when we're separated on money um that
that being in the same account and then
on the same page does is remove all that
there is unity and that's a huge deal
for your marriage not just for your
money so really important step love
taking a call like that where they say
we've just made massive amount of
changes in 12 months which is the best
way to do something like this yeah you
know when you got to take on massive
change whether it be your physical life
your relationship life your money life
your work life just get after it go
ahead and make the change and go so I
love that all right let's go to Kansas
City
where Troy joins us Troy how can we
help hey guys appreciate you taking my
call just just wanted to uh ask you
quickly so I'm I'm 33 my wife's 32 um we
uh we are going to be able to pay off
for our house here in uh in the next
probably month and a half to two months
awesome just depending on what our
expenses are but really what we're
looking for is the next steps right um
neither of us are very comfortable or
experienced in investing and we're
looking for what would be a good
strategy for us being the age we are um
you know kind of kind of what we should
be looking into and what we should be
putting uh our money into fantastic you
guys are crushing it man you're going to
be in your early 30s without a house
payment which means baby step seven
which means instead of investing 15% you
can increase that and you're going hey
what do we do now as far as
investing sure yep exactly cool what's
your current retirement options through
your employ
ERS yeah so me currently um I get a 4%
match um so we we've I've had that maxed
out since I've been working um you know
just the 4% but you know I haven't
personally been doing the 15% my wife is
closer to that she also gets the 4%
match but um I can't remember what she
also gets like an 8% match for uh um
some sort of stock ownership I believe
okay so let's get get some clarity on
what all of the options are and then
you're going to filter it through this
really simple strategy match beats Roth
beats traditional so if you both have a
match let's invest at least up to the
match if you guys have Roth options like
a Roth IRA let's Max those out for the
year beyond that you can go back to the
traditional side now if you max out all
of that including in HSA if you guys
have an a health savings account which
you can invest through then you might
want to look into a taxable brokerage
account outside of
retirement okay do it did any of that
click or you like what the heck did he
just say yeah no no I do I do believe
well my wife does have um Roth currently
through her work as an option so I know
that is an option for her um we we I
don't so I've been kicking around the
idea of getting one you know outside of
of my employment what kind of account do
you have through your
employer I just have the uh 401K a
traditional 401K they don't have a Roth
option for that
correct okay okay so for you you might
go max out the Roth IRA and then go back
to the traditional 401k and Max that out
but that would be my goal for you guys
is can we max out all of our retirement
options that are tax advantage for the
year that's a really great goal to
have because if you both do what's your
household
income yeah so I make just depending on
the bonus for the year I make around 120
to 150 a year and my wife is right
around the 100,000 a year oh my gosh you
guys are amazing so you're making
250,000
about to have no house payment you
absolutely both of you should be maxing
out those 401ks maxing out an IRA if
your income is above the threshold you
can look into something called a
backdoor Roth IRA and your next step cuz
I can tell you need some homework here
you need someone to walk you through
this give you some perspective on the
stock market squel some of the fears
contact a smartvestor pro you can
connect with one at ramsy solutions.com
and uh through our smartvestor program
we got investing Pros out there they're
not connected to our team but we trust
them to help you take the right Next
Step to build wealth and they're going
to take good care of you yeah I love it
you guys have such a bright future love
it good stuff George um so fun when you
kind of see the light bulb for people
yeah it's really fun all right don't
move more of your calls coming up this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
preapproval and a secured interest rate
plus a $55,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campell joins me the
phone number is 88255 225 taking your
money questions of course and I'm in
today so be taking any work related
questions as well and hey if you're
enjoying the show you can help us grow
by subscribing uh leaving a very nice
review if you don't mind and sharing
with a friend that all helps us uh help
more people get some real hope in their
life so thank you for thatle 88255 225
is the number let's go to Simone who
joins us in Baltimore Maryland Simone
how can we
help hi um well I'm 25 and I don't have
a college degree and I'm unemployed but
I'm in a lawsuit right now that's about
to reach
settlement and so I'm going to have
about three around three million after I
pay my lawyer and I don't know what to
do with it and I don't want to mess it
up wow now how confident are you that
this number is what you're getting you
said it's about to settle so is this
just all about signing dotting the eyes
crossing the tees just curious before we
jump into the advice on the money how
confident are you that it is in fact 3
million that you'll be walking away
with uh like
85% okay do you have any idea what the
range would
be uh definitely definitely three
million or more oh okay oh okay I got
you three million or more okay there you
go George how about that that's a lot of
money so my first question is is this
going to be taxable income or do you are
you confident that it will be
taxfree yep it's taxfree
wow and how much money do you have
currently zero well not zero I probably
have like $100 sping right now that's
pretty close to zero yeah okay so this
is lifechanging money and you're calling
us to go I don't want to screw this up I
want to be a good Steward of this money
and use it wisely do you need any of
this money as long as possible
absolutely and I think you can do that
um I'm glad you're calling us and not
you know going on a spending spree and
then calling us later saying I blew 3
million what do I do now so I'm glad
we're on the other side of it one
question George before you break the
numbers down in the investing side of
this and saving are you planning to to
work in the in the near
future uh yeah I mean I I was a college
student and I left school because I had
to take care of my family um and now I'm
kind of just fig trying to figure out
because I don't want to go back into
that I already paid the college um loans
off good um and I am in De $112,000 but
not from uh student loans I just like if
I go back to school that's that's
another thing like should I pay it out
of pocket or should I or should I take
the loans out and then I'm like no
you're gonna have enough money a
certificate I don't got to go to college
that's the issue any that's why I'm
asking that like what is it that you
want to
do I just want to I mean I I I don't
really want to work for anybody you work
for yourself I work for
anybody but I do I mean I don't mind
what having uh like I don't mind I don't
mind like having my own business but
that's never really cross my mind okay
well I tell you what I don't want to
Sidetrack you here we've got some
resources George I want to give her
towards the end of this call to kind of
help you can afford your path but I was
just curious here's what I don't want
I'm just going to say this uh I don't
want you even though you don't work for
anybody else longterm shortterm I want
you to start working even if it's just a
day job to be able to bring in income so
that we're not just living off this
excuse me yeah this is I did have a job
I just quit it in October I just I mean
I was just I my job is really Inc
consistent with communication and act
over it okay good all right yeah there's
two pieces here we got to find you a
career you love regardless of this money
and then the other side is we want to
Steward this wisely so do you have any
debt right
now yes I'm uh about I have let me see
like maybe like 15,000 in debt okay what
kind of debt is that
uh it's probably like 3,000 in um c
credit cards and then the rest is from
like a car loan okay so when will you
get the settlement money when will
actually show up in a bank
account uh in the next three months and
is this a lump sum you're getting $3
million just on a check or wired to your
bank
account um yeah it'll be wired to my
bank uh well my my lawyer said that it's
going to be a check with both of our
names on it whose our
names like my name and my lawyer's name
like his law the law for okay is he
getting a cut of the three
million no it's going to be where we're
actually sending them for six six and
then um but I was like if
i% yeah okay so there's a few things I
want to tell you number one the best
thing to do with this money is just
filter it through the baby steps and so
as soon as you get that money let's pay
off the debt and get you a fully funded
emergency fund in place which is going
to be six months of expenses for you so
we pay off 15K and then let's stack up
let's say what 30k would that be a full
emergency fund for you yeah that should
be good and what that does that's a
never get into debt again fund isn't it
you never need a car loan again in fact
I would cut up the credit cards today
and be done with them forever cuz you
just became your own bank you don't need
Capital ones
help and it's it's going to cause you to
make different decisions when you use
Simone's money versus Capital 1's money
so I'm going to encourage you to cut up
the cards as well now Beyond getting out
of debt getting the emergency fund in
place I want you to have a reliable
reasonable car and maybe a home that's
reasonable as well and you could pay
cash for those things now couldn't
you yeah are you renting right
now um actually I live rentree right now
because I'm living with my sister cool
um yeah and do you plan on staying in
Baltimore more long
term uh no I want to move to Korea whoa
well that's a
dream yeah okay and this money could set
you up for that if that's your goal now
are you going to be working there what's
the goal of moving to
Korea I do want to work uh actually I
think I I want to work for an American
company and then workn Korea now wait a
second what happened to the person who
said they didn't want to work for
anybody wanted to work for
themselves well I either whatever
there's like this part of me that's like
I have to work the rest of my life but
then there's I've been reading so many
books in the last six months that I'm
like well I don't want to work for
anybody but there's still this part of
me that's like I need to get a job yeah
well let's a couple things you don't
have to work for the rest of your life
you do what George tells you right now
with this and you invest this wisely uh
you're going to be fine and there's a
point where you won't you'll get to
decide how you work when you work
whatever but you read these books and
I'm not going to make you name these
books but you be very very careful of
how we let content sway us and that
includes by the way anything I say
George says like you got to be able to
receive something and then process it
and not let it completely change your
direction unless you decide so I I think
that you need to figure out what is it
that I'm really really good at doing
what is it that I really enjoy doing and
then what results do I want to put out
into the world right does that make
sense
yeah and I think if you play around with
that you can figure that out in fact I'm
going to give you my get clear
assessment takes about 15 20 minutes
it's going to measure your skill set
what you do best it's going to measure
what you love to do work that brings you
enjoyment then what motivates you and
and we'll give you the book from
paycheck to purpose as well which kind
of gives you a very clear path of how I
go from ideation to activation make
sense okay those are my gifts to you
okay but but you're you're going to be
fine financially if you take George's
advice so Simone here's your next steps
on the financial side you need to
assemble a Dream Team around you and
what that's going to look like for you
is a really great insurance broker cuz
you need an umbrella policy to cover you
now on top of great Auto Insurance
homeowners insurance you name it and on
top of that you're going to want to have
a great lawyer that may not be the
lawyer you currently have you may want
uh to have a great accountant in your
corner to handle all the tax
implications as you move forward and uh
maybe a real estate agent as well and
good news for you you can connect with
all of those trusted pros at Ramsey
solutions.com to help you but let me
encourage you even if you pay off debt
you put 30,000 in the emergency fund you
buy a
$450,000 house that still leaves you
with 2.5 million
correct uh yes now if you invest that
2.5 million and you can get connected
with an investing pro at ramsy
solutions.com they can help you with
this if you just invested that into the
stock market and you saw returns of
let's say 8 to 11% you could have
anywhere from $40 million to $100
million
when you turn 60 does that blow your
mind yes and so that's the power of
compound growth and letting this money
grow for you so that you never have to
worry about money again and I I have
faith you'll get there don't go blow
this money walk slowly use the resources
that Ken's going to send you yeah you
got this Simone we believe in you hang
on we got some goodies for you
appreciate the call good hour George
camell thank you sir thanks to James
Childs our fearless leader and all the
gang in the booth that keep us on the
air thank you America for listening this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help you win in your life
specifically with your money your work
and in your relationships 88255 225 is
the number for you to jump in we'd love
to talk with you I'm Ken Coleman George
camel joins me we're Ramsey
personalities and we are here here for
you I'll help you on any work rated
questions chime in on the money stuff
George will help you out on the money
stuff chime in on any work rated stuff
so we love taking your calls we're all
about helping you win so let's get to it
Sonia or Sonia I never know George we're
going to find son you feel like it's
Sonia yeah I'm gonna go with Sonia as
well we'll see Sonia is that how we say
your name in Dallas
Texas hi George hi Ken this is Sonia yes
Sonia we got it right okay it's such an
honor to speak with both of you I'm so
nervous my heart heart is pounding oh my
goodness well first of all all right
take a deep breath and know that you're
already doing a wonderful job so we're
here for you you can't you can't mess
this up because it's all about your
story so what's up all right so we have
two residences we have a rental property
out in Arkansas and we have a primary
residence out here in Dallas W worth
that we just bought last year and my
husband and I have been
at A T of war between whether we sell
the arkans of property it's a PID for
rental property um to pay off our
primary residents or I should rephrase
it's not to pay off but to expedite the
process of paying off our primary
residence he wants to keep the rental I
want to sell it so is this rental
property changing your life
financially
um yes in a way because that would mean
that it would like very quickly pay off
our primary residents um no I mean
currently with the rent you're getting
from this place and the headache is it
is it just like wow we're making 50
Grand a year from this
rental no we're not because um if if
it's okay I'd like to give you some
numbers sure um and so we we make um
pretty decent income we make about
220,000 um and we our rental property is
worth about 350 ,000 and our primary
residence which we still have a mortgage
on is about 5 48,000 we have no other
debt um we have a pretty um decent
retirement um 401K set up um and we're
you both under 40 so I think you know
either way I know that we'll be okay
it's just that for me I'm in a hurry
just to clear out all my debt so that we
can you know utilize that money towards
putting it towards so many other things
um he on the other hand wants to keep
his investment property because he feels
like he's never going to get um another
opportunity you know at that price that
we bought about seven years
ago okay what is this rental property
bringing
in it's bringing in about 24,000 a year
okay and that's on top of your
220 correct and what's your monthly
mortgage
payment here it's about 4,000
so you're telling me if you pay off this
mortgage you would have $4,000 back in
your life every
month yes which is double what you're
making from the rental
property yes and not to mention interest
because you know that's the killer
because we ended up buying it I think at
the peak um well it's still pretty bad
but I know last year right before it
kind of slowed down that's when we
bought our current home that we live in
so what's your interest rate on the
primary 5 5 okay and what's the mortgage
you said the 548 is that what's left on
the mortgage or is that what it's worth
it it's worth about 675 uh we have about
548 left okay yeah that's a hefty
mortgage makes sense that it's $4,000
with those interest rates uh and you're
going to take all of the equity all the
proceeds you get from the rental would
go onto your primary knocking it down to
about what that's what I would like yes
close to 200
left I mean after capital gains because
we haven't lived in that we've been
running it out for the last like four
years so after the capital gains I'm not
sure um but it's still a very
substantial amount that we would knock
it down to and you know it's just uh
it's just about you know I guess us
trying to be on the same page about it
but I am always you guys have really
changed our lives because I know we uh
found you in the pandemic and we had two
kids since the pandemic and we're just
trying to make sure that you know we're
we're on baby step 456 so you know we we
just want to make sure that you know
we're we're going to get to that uh
millionaire status very soon absolutely
well I'm on your team maybe not for the
same reasons but I think you know the
way we look at it is this and Ken chime
in on this if you were living in Texas
and you said hey we're looking at this
investment property in Arkansas that we
want to buy you wouldn't do that would
you it doesn't make sense to be a
long-distance landlord and so that's
kind of how I reverse engineer it to go
I'm selling this thing thing I know it's
be it's paid for which is awesome I love
that for you guys and the money is nice
especially when it's cash flowing like
that with no mortgage attached to it but
at the same time I think you guys are
going to be back there cuz think about
this you're going to have a little over
200 left on the mortgage you're making
220 you're going to pay that thing off
in two years and now you're making 220
with no mortgage which is going to free
up 50 Grand that you can then put
towards saving up for a new investment
property right and his argument is just
that he does not he doesn't think that
he's going to get an investment property
at such a look cuz when we bought it
seven years ago we bought it for like
200,000 and so he just feels like it's
just that's not going to happen now um
even after we pay off our primary
residence which I disagree with but I'm
just I'm trying to make this call just
so you know I'm able to persuade him um
you know that he does we end up selling
it and putting it towards their primary
Resident was kind of like a little
challenge cuz he was like why don't you
call B and find out and I'm like you
know what I will do it I'm glad you did
because he can watch this you can
actually watch this back George asked me
to chime in this is what I'm going to
say I think that what he has to
understand is that he's looking at this
from a scarcity mindset versus abundance
that's all a bunch of fancy stuff we
just break it down what that means is
he's going I if we sell this now we're
never going to find a property like this
again as opposed to what I thought
George laid out beautifully focus on
what this property because it's
debt-free and you can now sell it what
what does it do for your future he's
kind of in the past on this and he's
going well it's paid for it's thrown off
this but George is right it's long
distance it's it's a pain in the neck
and instead of looking at what do we got
to do to keep it it's celebrate what we
what we were going to do with it because
we can sell it I just think it's a shift
in mindset and he's worried about the
wrong thing as opposed to going wait a
second this is a massive fast forward
button that's what I think absolutely
and he also needs to remember that he
almost doubled the the home appreciation
herea he bought it at 200 now it's worth
350 Fant let's celebrate that that's a
huge win and it's one of the of real
estate leverage it just that's what you
have to think of is like how much
further we get far I mean get ahead in
life by leveraging this investment
that's the right kind of Leverage right
there it really is instead of debt
leverage so you guys have done a great
job though I'm proud of Sonia and her
husband I'm excited they're they're not
even 40 yet and here they are making
these kinds of choices yeah hopefully
hubs gets on board uh for the record
hubs George and I are with your wife um
that's three against one it's three
against one I'm not a math prodigy but I
think we're winning I I I think it's one
if it's a vote we vote it we'll see
we'll see what happens if only Congress
handled things that easily we'd be in a
better place but I digress amen he's
George Campell I'm Ken Coleman this is
the Ramsey Show don't move more coming
[Music]
up
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your healthc care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost Ministry
that has helped members take care of
nearly 10 billion in healthcare costs
chm is an affordable alternative to
insurance that gives you the freedom and
empowers you to live out your values and
you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me we are
here for you america8
[Music]
825-5222 that's the word you were
looking for I what you knew it too uh I
love a good uh usage of inextricable by
the way use that at your holiday parties
a little bonus and uh that's a 50 Cent
word that people go okay I was going to
go $10 Bob but you think it's $10 it's a
$10 word okay very good uh Hey listen
let me tell you what I think is is maybe
one of the most invaluable shows we do
here at the Ramy uh Network and and the
Ramsey Show and that's our giving
edition of the ramay show it's a fan
favorite we do this every year around
around Christmas time what does that
mean we want to hear your stories you're
always the star of the show as we take
your calls but we want to flip it a
little bit and you say you're the star
uh but you're going to share stories
doesn't have to be a story about you
specifically could involve you but it is
a giving story maybe you've tipped the
waitress a 100 bucks or you bought
Thanksgiving dinner or toys for for for
Tots that needed who knows maybe you've
been on the receiving end of an
unbelievable gift and uh you want to
thank that person or persons who gave to
you we want to hear it go to Ramsey
solutions.com askk that's ramsy
solutions.com
askk and put giving in the subject line
uh and we do this every year around
Christmas time it's coming up it'll be
here before you know it know it George
December 18th by the way it's probably
time for you to start shopping for your
old pal Ken Coleman yeah your desk mate
that's speaking of generosity we'll see
how generous I feel this okay
season I'll try to be nicer throughout
the rest of the show how many cashmir
sweaters do you need Ken that's all I'm
saying well you know you need one of
every color don't forget the cardigan
cashmir is the double combo if you
really love me that's what you'll get me
just so you can make more fun of me uh
but I digress December 18th the giving
show as you know for decades Davis
challenged us all to live like no one
else so later you can give like no one
else we'd love to hear your story all
right it's time for our question of the
day brought to you by neighborly I feel
like we need jingle on this I don't
think they want it from us I'll tell you
that much I think they probably would
like it if you and I harmonized
neighborly and kind of went up kind of
just the octave change yeah let's work
on that yeah we're going to work on that
we'll see how that goes James is shaking
his head vociferously right now uh your
hub for Home Services is neighborly when
you need to make repairs schedule
routine maintenance or get local help
for Home Improvement projects like
George and I need because we can't do
anything around the house go to
neighbor.com
Ramsey your source to find and schedule
reliable home service providers in your
area today's question comes from Maria
in Arizona I'm trying to make a decision
I recently started a new job but I feel
like the nature of the work is not my
passion however the job pays really well
I'm making around $91,000 but I'm
thinking about going into another
position where I would be taking a
drastic pay cut more like
$442,000 but I feel like this other
position would be less stressful and
somewhere I could make more of an impact
but I'm not sure it's the right decision
how do you balance pay with something
you feel called to oh I love this
question I love this question and can I
just tell you tell me he's not here
today but Dave kind of doesn't like it
when I throw this out there and and and
uh let me tell you what I think about
this um and I base this on fact Ramsey
Solutions George as you know has done
the largest study of net worth
millionaires all time over 10,000 number
three in the top three group of of of
network millionaires were teachers so
what that tells us all of us is that you
can become a millionaire by living on
less than you make and that is largely
driven George by
contentment contentment with your
contribution uh you know as delone says
sometimes are you willing to live a a
Civic life you know a Honda Civic you
willing to drive these things are you
willing to live in a ranch that maybe
was built in 1955 that that's the idea
and in America's consumer culture it's
more and more bigger increasingly nicer
that's right so I that's philosophically
setting up my answer here and I believe
that if um Maria can live off of 42k
versus 91 that's a big cut George but if
she and her family in that situation
they don't go into a super tight
paycheck to paycheck style of living uh
then then I'm all for it so if you can
afford it do it now the the caveat there
is what must I do to be able to afford
working in a $42,000 job and if you can
do it and you're content in it I say
absolutely do it and I think that we're
seeing this younger generation I'm
having some fascinating conversations
with Tai my oldest you know Jin Z is
thinking more and more about contentment
they really are about the kind of Life
they want to live well they've seen
their parents work jobs they hate they
don't like the rat race they're watching
it and they're going I don't get it
we're seeing more and more of these
videos pop up on Tik Tok and I and I
actually applaud them and so in this
situation uh if you can manage the
DraStic pay cut but on the back side of
it you're not hurting yourself
financially putting yourself in a
negative situation and you are content
and fulfilled I say absolutely do it
yeah I like that how controversial is
that George um I think you have a great
point it's not all you can't just look
at well I would never take a pay cut uh
I've been there and you might take the
pay cut temporarily now my goal for
Maria is that if it's something she
loves doing that tells me that she's
probably going to be really good at it
cuz she's focused and intense about it
which tells me she's probably going to
be making more money soon and so I would
be looking at the overall trajectory she
may it may be a different she might not
be making $100,000 ever doing this don't
know I want to use an extreme example
here to make a bigger point if we could
um Mother Teresa
lives her life that's an extreme example
I understand but but the point is made
this is a woman who was given to
Ministry and service and she decided to
live she changed her lifestyle to be
able to do the things she was called to
I'm not saying we all are called to
Poverty but are you willing to make the
sacrifices needed to do that mission
that's the issue what's driving you
stuff or significance I do think it's
that simple and I think you can change
your lifestyle to fit that I really do I
believe that I believe that
yeah if we were on the phone with Maria
we'd have a lot a better picture of what
her financial life looks like if this is
a good idea right now but that's a great
answer Ken all right let's get to Joe in
Washington DC Joe how can we
help hi um yeah I was just calling
because I have uh some student loan debt
um and I was just wondering the best
ways I should go about handling that
okay how much student loan debt do you
have I have just under 40,000 uh 38,000
okay and are you working in a job right
now if so what do you make I am um right
now I make uh 4,000 a month after taxes
okay any other debt besides the student
loan debt nope just student loans no
credit card or anything else great how
many how many student loans do you have
if you broke them all out how many are
there uh I believe four okay awesome so
if you look at the smallest debt uh you
want to attack that one first first
while making minimum payments on the
rest that's called the debt snowball
method it's just smallest to largest
balance Focus intensity on the smallest
one and I had a very similar situation
of yours I had 36,000 in student loan
debt and I paid it off in 18 months and
I wasn't even making what you were
making how'd you do it George it was
side hustles Lean Cuisines uh living on
less than I make saying no to friends
keeping my lifestyle in check all of
those things over 18 months you start to
go all right this becomes a math problem
doesn't it 13 if you make $4,000 a month
you have 38,000 in student loan debt I
want you to pay it off in 18 months you
need to be putting over 2,000 a month
toward your student loans can you do
that currently with your
budget I I believe I can but I I also
have uh 42,000 in savings oh my gosh my
one predicament was if I should just
why' you bury the lead my
man okay this becomes a lot easier tell
him George we got 50 seconds how pay off
today that leaves you with four grand
right
yes now we're going to build a fully
funded emergency fund from there with
this new found money because you just
freed up all those
payments I'm telling you it's worth it
you wouldn't be calling to the show if
you were debt free and it tells me you
don't want this debt in your life you
have the money to pay it off I know it
hurts cuz You' worked so hard to build
that 42,000 but it had Sally May's name
on it and it still does until you're
free from her break the chain my man pay
it off you won't you will not regret it
and you're going to be back to having
that 40K in savings real soon Sally and
Fanny May the sisters of misery get them
out of there yeah of misery it sounds
like a rock and roll uh yeah nice ladies
though really you get to know I'm
kidding sarcasm folks tell you a fun
Story coming back right after the break
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're so
thrilled you're with us we're here to
help help you win in your money and in
your work today I'm Ken Coleman George
Campell joins me uh folks it is that
time of the year where you got to get
that gift and and can we be honest with
you for for just a moment uh as if we're
not going to be honest the rest of the
show I don't know what that means what a
nice change of pace Ken that you're
going to be honest yeah we're going to
be honest so uh the the the uh the
amount of gifts we feel pressure to buy
in America around Christmas time it's
endless George I feel it you used to be
the family and then it was like well our
uncle Uncle Larry and Aunt Ma coming in
well we got to get him something we got
to get Aunt Ma you know it's like and
then at what point you go well we're not
going to send gifts you know away
anymore it's just all the stress around
Gift buying it's a lot all right then
you got the office gifts do you buy a
gift for the boss do you get it for the
coworker I mean I try to put as much
pressure on you as possible to getan
show team I know they're they're getting
some nice gifts this year yeah the
isotoners are going to be great uh
thanks to Dan Marino but uh but you know
it's like but okay so what do I get what
if I get a gift that keeps on giving and
this is not the jello jelly of the month
club from National Lampoon is it Jello-O
or jelly I think it's jelly I think it's
jelly uh how about meaningful gifts in
our $12 sale at Ramsey Solutions our
bestselling books like Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaire uh own
your past change your future don't
forget from paycheck to purpose just
$122 each uh Quest is for human cards
there's only3 00 of those decks so
something for something for everybody I
think they have it for dogs at this
point I saw one the other day it was
question for humans octogenarian version
so wow if you're hanging out at the the
uh old folks hall for those that have
some years experience yeah you know cuz
you know that's like a decade sensitive
type deck there you know true uh so
that's out there all kinds of great
stuff at Ramy solutions.com store
ramseys solutions.com store check it out
you can't beat that sale so there you go
fun stough all right to the phones we go
Detroit Michigan is where Andrew joins
us Andrew how can we
help hi guys thank you for taking my
call you bet what's
up a few years ago I I start working my
9 to-5 to do ride chair and uh recently
they said uh that uh we can't do the
ride chair the luxury ride chair anymore
so I've been going through my savings
but most importantly my daughter helped
me purchase the car for lift and I been
hearing on your show that they we should
just sell these bad loans or cars with
bad loans but um we're pretty underwater
on the car and I was wondering how do I
go about selling the car that you're uh
underwater on and how can I improve my
situation until I find another job
basically what were you doing before
ride
chair I was working as a technical
writer okay were you making more money
doing ride shair is that why you quit
it exactly I started making about $300
more a week and I had more time for
myself so I said it sounds like a better
gig so I I started working less hours
doing RI share and earning a little more
money okay now what happens when you get
rid of this car because you just lost
your full-time job
essentially exactly uh well basically
the I don't I have I haven't paid for a
car so I have a car that I can drive oh
you got two cars one is for ride shair
one is your your personal
essentially uh yes well now it is I had
it like an old beater send in a backyard
that I never drove but now I if I can
get rid of the car I don't mind dve so
you're upside down my wife has very very
much so all right give us the
numbers uh it's I still owe about 50 a
little more than 52 and it's only worth
about 25 what car is
this this is a the model X and I used it
for uh luxury driving and they said LIF
I said we're not going to do Luxury
driving anymore in my area so I can't uh
it can't support it when I was when it
was going strong I had no issues at all
I got nice budget but now I'm going
through all me and my life savings and
I'm trying to see what year is it why do
you think it's only worth 25k is just
super high mileage because of how much
driving you
do uh the mileage and the condition and
they they they don't have a good resale
value to begin with
so well what year is it this is a 2016
okay so it's older but you bought it
brand new back in
2016 I did not I bought it used a few
years ago and you still had a $52,000
loan on
it exactly yes oh man well you probably
bought it the height on top of you know
the market car market taking a dip oh
boy okay how much money do you have in
savings uh I've been we've been going I
went through my savings trying to find
another job so I don't have anything I
have about
$1,200 and my guess is your credit is
shot considering your daughter had to
co-sign for
you indeed it is goodness gracious yeah
when you said my daughter help she did
not help you she enabled a terrible
financial decision that she's now caught
up
in two two CRA two bad financial
decisions what is her Financial
State uh you mean my daughter
yeah uh it's okay I helped her uh get a
buy a house a few years ago and the uh
the car is actually doing damage to her
as well I did tell her to get a house I
think y'all need to stop helping each
other because it usually ends up with
bad decisions being made yeah I was
going to say let's let her do her thing
and you do your
thing yeah May so so George I think
there's no short sell option here
because he can't get a loan from a
credit union going give you the
difference I think you're going to be
working yourself to almost asleep you're
working like crazy and way better pay
you're not driving anymore but you got
to pay this thing off or at least pay it
down to where you can make a little
something on it you still owe
52 I still a little more than 52 yes sir
what was the original
balance uh was around 60 I didn't
originally have it for uh Riot share but
I got it because of the free it was was
free gas or free energy I didn't have to
pay for for the energy to use I was us
the r sh I was paying for a lot of gas
all that might as well Boy free energy
going 60 Grand into debt for free
energy basically yeah okay well you you
can try going to you know where the loan
is held and walking into that bank and
saying I need to talk to the manager
here's the situation you guys have a bad
loan on your hands CU this car is only
worth this much I owe this much I need
to the difference in a loan so I can pay
down that 25 or 27 or whatever the
difference is in order to get out from
under this that's the only way you're
going to get out of this thing other
than just paying it
down okay or saving up the difference
and then selling it but and you got to
fight for it those are three tough
options but you got to fight for it you
got to really convince them that they're
going to get their 25 or 27 back they're
probably not going to get the 50
whatever and and you got to hope that
they look at that and they believe you
and and there's your shot and you can
pay that off a lot quicker than you can
the 52 but I mean you're going to need
another job a couple of jobs yeah yeah
I'm I'm looking out to do a replacement
I thought I could try to find something
that make the same amount but I'm going
to be selling here shortly I need to get
back in the workplace but again two or
three jobs four jobs selling everything
else you got anything else you can
sell uh my house
actually well that's an extreme
situation but then you're going to have
a you you said you own it free and
clear uh technically because I bought it
and then I maxed out some credit cards
to get it but to get it uh operational
but yes it's technically free and clear
besides the credit cards that I mixed
out to make it right okay and I would do
some more homework on that car value
because I'm looking it up right now it
seems real low uh what I'm seeing online
right now is anywhere from 33 to 40 is
what that car should be worth so before
or you just go it's worth 25 you might
have a shorter Gap or smaller Gap than
you think you do and that could give you
some hope to get out of this thing
sooner okay okay yeah tell him what tell
you that's just a same area as he is in
then I just did my ZIP code with a 100
mile radius and see what these cars are
going for 2016 model XY so Andrew let's
go let's go multiple sites get the value
up on that let's get the most we can get
to the bank and get busy you got to
change this stuff and I would not right
now sell that house we want to hold on
to that if you if you own that that's a
last ditch effort to avoid bankruptcy
don't don't rush into that thank you for
the call this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show so
excited to have you with us as we talk
with you about you specifically your
life we want to help you win financially
and a big part of that is winning
professionally and so I'm Ken Coleman
the work personality here at Ramy
Solutions George camel one of our
financial and money personalities is
with me today triple 88 25 5225 how can
George and I help you uh in those areas
we'd love to hear from youle
5225 speaking of how we can help you uh
for years we've talked to people about
knowing where your money is where is it
going why is it going there is a part of
the process of the baby steps that we
teach to help you win with money and
every dollar is our worldclass budgeting
app that helps you manage money the
ramsy way you can start every dollar for
free and immediately to see where you
stand with your money it helps you get
organized personalize your budget Stop
overspending and Save if you're brand
new to every dollar we'll show you a
long-term Financial road map track your
net worth debt free date retirement date
baby step progress and so much more it's
just walking alongside of you taking the
stress out of this process and we want
you we want you to actually engage in
this app it'll help you build wealth and
reach your financial goals you can
download the free app for IOS and
Android or go to everydollar.com to get
started that's every dollar.
by the way do you have something going
on a webinar of sorts is that already
happened Rachel did one today but we do
them ongo and so Rachel Jade and I have
been doing these really fun webinars at
everydollar.com budgeting we always let
people know when the next one's coming
up but they're just free they're hour
long and we kind of onboard people show
them all the features and show them how
it can create margin and peace in their
look out for that every doll.com
budgeting uh get on board in the next
one it's really a fun way to kind of
Kick the tires and and realize it's
easier than you think so there you go
all right to the phones we go Chicago is
where Kyle joins us Kyle how can we
help hi uh thank you for taking my call
how are you doing today we're doing
great what's going on with you so just a
little bit of backstory uh I'm on baby
step number three uh so trying to save 3
six months of emergency fund um but I
own a townhouse in the Chicago land area
but my cousin goes to University of teny
Knoxville and uh my uncle and I were
thinking about going in on a townhouse
for her and a couple roommates together
so I was just wanted your opinion if I
should go in with my uncle on that
Financial investment or if I should hold
off until I basically pay off my town
home mortgage until I basically try to
invest in real estate
further well I think you know the answer
you called our show and you know when
investing in real estate would fall into
the baby steps and that's after you have
your primary home paid off and you do it
with cash and so no I would not step
into this and there's other reasons too
this just sounds messy you're going into
this deal with a family member and
equity and deeds and it's long distance
there's a lot that I don't like about
this plan
truthfully in your financial position as
well being in baby step three you don't
have an emergency fund in place you
don't have your town home paid off it
sounds like
correct correct I do not have it paid
off currently there's about uh I've paid
off about 58,000 but there's still about
182 left to go okay and this would
obviously slow down your your financial
progress
there correct yeah and you don't have
any money to put into this investment do
you have separate
savings yes I do so I have uh about
13,000 in a CD right now that would
mature before we would go in on the
investment so that would be around
14,000 and then I have 10,000 in my
savings which is kind of the building
blocks for my emergency fund and then I
have about 5,000 in my checking and then
about 33,000 between a
401k uh HSA and uh stock market okay
well if you have anything that's
non-retirement I think you could
liquidate that to help speed up the
emergency fund and I would use that CD
money to fully fund your emergency fund
and I wouldn't have done the CD to begin
with because of how a liquid it is but
that's for another time but I would
focus on the baby steps right now you're
doing a lot at once I assume you're
investing as
well uh just through my 401k but in the
stock market I'm kind of holding off on
that for now until I get in a better
financial position yeah so I mean you're
doing Kyle's plan which is fine you're
there I'm not saying you won't succeed
in that but I'm telling you when you
follow a proven plan and you just pause
investing let's get the baby uh the
emergency fund set up in baby step three
let's begin investing the right way 15%
into retirement let's pay off the house
and let's save that investment property
for a later date and I would do it on
your terms and I would not do it long
distance and I probably wouldn't involve
family because that just is it's going
to get messy and we' we that too much on
this
show okay yeah know that's
understandable but thank you for your
opinion and abs absolutely not the
answer he wanted to hear I could tell
but can the amount of time someone
called into the show and said I went in
on this investment property with my
uncle long distance and it has worked
out amazingly well that's right it's
usually I went in on this deal with my
uncle and you're the last call we make
until we go to the People's Court you I
mean by the way who's there now is Judge
wapner's long gone who's uh you know I
don't know as astute as I am I've not
kept up with the roster of who's running
who's the latest judge but we're having
a little fun with the fact that it's
just a mess yeah cuz what happens later
on down the road uncle wants to sell he
needs the money you don't want to sell
there's capital gains that's right who's
going to go deal with the HVAC situation
well if Uncle Larry's taken care of it
you know and he can't do it anymore
because of his gout you know kind of
kicked up no pun intended then you know
we got a problem just stay out of the
family real estate everything looks good
on paper until life happens is that true
and that's what we deal with on the show
is on the other side when life happened
and it didn't work out all right life
happens caller after caller Pat is now
joining us in Birmingham Pat how can we
help hey how's it going um my question
is um I have uh ASB bestus in my popcorn
ceiling oh and I'm wondering if it
constitutes an emergency fund draw um
I'm trying to save up for my three to
six month emergency fund about 6,000
right now and the job would cost um
around 8 to 10,000 o um they've offered
uh to to do like payments for three
payments three equal payments um but I'm
just not sure if I should if I should
pull the trigger on it right now could
you cash flow it with the three equal
payments I think so and is it this isn't
uh no no interest
correct right George what do you think
about that I mean that would be you
you've got to fix this ASAP you can't
live there
right yeah I mean from what I've heard
as long as you don't like touch and and
you don't mess with it then then it's
fine um a lot of people have said just
remediate the one spot um you know but
uh for resale purposes and and just for
peace of mind I would rather get the
whole house done and that would cost you
eight you
said yeah have you got a few bids
without the eight without the drywall
finishing the ceiling finishing uh and
then probably about 10 with the ceiling
refinished how quickly could you save up
two grand if you sold stuff got a side
job whatever it took could you do that
in a week or two three weeks a
month probably about a month or two okay
I'm wondering if we start on this thing
and you attempt to cash flow it
whatever's left you make a payment the
following month and finish it off with
them you make that agreement with them
on paper yeah but and this is not ideal
but just from a cash flow perspective
George if if you could put up with it
um if you're okay living for three four
five six months with just the uh it's
safy issue once the drywall's in if
you're comfortable looking at that dry
finish it later finish it a little bit
later I'm just saying that's an option
yeah when we talk about C is this your
entire family is it
you uh yeah it's my family it's my wife
and two children oh the wife is probably
not going to go for that I got a strong
feeling
right yeah I mean yeah I mean like it it
would be better if we had the ceiling
finished yeah well again George is okay
with the cash flow that's what I was
thinking long as it's not debt and we're
not any interest payments on that and
they're giving you they're going to work
with you I think that's fantastic and
and and I'd still get a few bids I would
too and even say hey if I do all six you
know six grand up front cash would you
guys be willing to work with me on this
and they may may be willing to do that
to have some instant cash flow maybe um
don't get your hopes up on these trades
sometimes a cash deal makees I get you
know even on the trades where they're
just in demand well sometimes you you
get cold hard cash and they like that
when you flash the green K just saying
did you say cold hearted cold heart Hard
Cash oh cold hearted cash cold hard okay
I see to to the question if it's urgent
unexpected and necessary it's an Emer
you pull from the emergency fund if you
can't say yes to all those it's probably
justification but I like this case I
like this situation I think he can cash
flow PR serious I think he can cash flow
it which is a good move all right good
advice George as always good hour to my
friend and to James Childs our fearless
leader and the crew in the booth thank
you thank you America for listening this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
m live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions this is the ramsy show where
we help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and in your relationships the phone
number to jump in is 8825 5225 I'm Ken
Coleman honored to be joined by my pal
George camel who got a special delivery
we'll talk about that a little bit later
we'll just tease what a tease yeah
Special Delivery during the uh break but
we're excited to be with you 8825 522 5
let's go to Knoxville Tennessee and I
believe this is Ali uh or Ali I'm not
sure is it Ali it's Ally all right
excellent good guest today all right so
what's going on Ally how can we help
yeah first I want to thank you for
taking my call um my husband and I are
leaning towards the idea of selling our
house and we wanted to get an idea if
we're doing the right thing and if we do
sell the house that we we have a good
plan
with the money okay what's driving you
to this
decision I'm drowning in bills and I'm
pretty much the so
provider um and I just want relief we've
grown out of our home pretty much um
we've done pretty much everything to it
part of the reason why we're in debt is
we had to get new Plumbing we had to get
a new ageback and with all those loans
I'm pretty much taking all of my
take-home pay and paying the mortgage
and drowning in the interest from the
loans so what how much Consumer Debt do
you guys
have um so as far as like credit
cards um everything but the mortgage
say okay I would
say
40,000 okay and what's the
mortgage um we owe
105 all right and what is the household
income
um 7 to 8,000 a
month yeah is that gross or
take-home um gross okay so you're making
close to six figures and that's just you
you said your husband is he not working
outside the home is he with the kids
what's he
doing yeah he is uh going to school and
mostly stays home with our daughter but
he does go he does go to work two a week
so he's making about 1,200 a month okay
and that's adding to the seven or
eight no that's combined with it okay
got it so why are things so tight it
doesn't sound like the the payments on
the mortgage and the consumer debt
payments you shouldn't be
drowning there are multiple loans so the
interest with the loans like we have a
few payday loans oh my gosh and just
like yeah why did you have to turn to
Payday Loans was your credit
shot yeah my credit is
shot okay well the good news is you guys
have a great income and I think we can
even up the income and Ken can help with
that to get out of this debt fast these
payday loans are scum of the earth and
when you look at what the interest rate
amounts to it can be 300% which is why
you feel like you're
drowning yeah it's just a Vortex where
the the balance never goes down because
of how high this interest is so I'm
sorry you're dealing with that uh we
want to get you on a path to get rid of
all of this so what is your smallest
debt that you have right
now the smallest debt I would say um a
credit a credit card like you have a few
credit cards that only have about $2 to
$300 left on them okay so you can knock
that out today
probably correct not really no I think
they're I think they're paycheck I think
they're paycheck to paycheck so you have
nothing are you able to cover all of
your bills currently are you behind on
any oh uh yeah we've had to not pay some
bills because at the end of the month I
mean there's still there's still stuff
that needs paid okay now I just want to
jump in really quick because I'm just
curious is it all the debt payments that
are making you be delinquent in other
payments or is it you guys have no idea
where your money's going you're not
doing a budget and you guys just you're
not even sure where it's
going um I would say it's a little bit
of both it's like we have so much in
debt I just pay what I can in debt and
then groceries I try to set a limit but
regardless we're always short even
whenever we do set a budget I'm really
confused where all this money is going
what is your total Consumer Debt add up
to in payments every
month um
about 5,000
$5,000 and that's aside from the
mortgage what's the mortgage payment 500
oh my
gosh okay well we're going to have to up
the income and start knocking these
debts out until you get rid of some of
these ankle biters it'll free up a
payment um is there anything you can
sell is are any of these debts like a
car or something before you go to sell
the house is there anything
else uh I mean I have a car but I'm
upside down on it and my h truck I mean
it's worth
$500 okay and that's included in the 40K
of debt that you
mentioned yeah his car is paid off mine
um my car is a part of the 40,000 that I
mentioned how
much how much do I owe or how much is it
worth both
both um so I
owe about
8,000 and I think it's
worth
6,000 it's 7,000 I would say okay so
it's probably worth just keeping that
and paying it off and driving it yeah
yeah and I would like to add that my
income the amount it's pretty new I
started making that income around
August um okay so that's another reason
behind is yeah but look you guys are
working extra jobs what's he doing in
school can he pause that while we get
out of this
mess um well he's going on the Tennessee
promise so he gets free schooling
basically if he doesn't
quit well he's going to need to be
working full-time as a student and
full-time working because we we can't
sustain this as it vortexes with
interest we got to get rid of these
payday loans yeah you guys aren't even
talking to each other other than to say
hi bye and the budget meeting you're
working like crazy you have got to do
this but if you get after it and you
really work like crazy get a true budget
and start knocking these debts off and
getting yourself out of this uh you can
you can recover from this and and change
your life but it's going to have to be
super intense to to start to to chip
away at
this yeah but hear me say it's
doable it's a great math problem when
you're making 100K you got 40K in debt
if you can throw 6K a month at this debt
it'll be gone in about 6 months yeah
talking short-term Sprint can you do
that we lost I mean you don't know I'm
here I think I think it's just trying to
up the
income not really sure that's not hard
part of the equation sweetheart you are
you are doing anything and everything
you're there are people that are looking
for people to work all the time this is
not a another career move this is extra
jobs side hustles you're doing
everything I tell you what I want want
to do uh hang on the line we're going to
get you a session a free session on us
with one of our financial coaches just
to kind of help set this path forward so
you can believe what George and I are
telling you and I think that session is
going to help you so hang on the line
Austin will take care of that you guys
can do this get busy though this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
W welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by George camel we
are here for you to answer your money
questions your work questions and on and
on and we love coaching you up so we'd
love to hear from you triple 825 5225
okay uh real estate reality here let's
let's talk about this in the news all
the time the average interest rate for
15year fix rate mortgage George uh
dropped from
7.03% to 6.56 in the past month so hey I
mean that's not nothing when we start to
see rates like they were they were
sniffing eight and you know w we were
just thought it was going to continue to
go up and up and up yeah so if this
trend continues George what happens what
do you what do you see well a lot of
people that have been on the sidelines
that have been waiting trying to kind of
time this Market they may want to take
advantage of these lower rates and that
small drop uh in percentages that can
actually mean huge savings talking about
thousands and thousands of dollars over
time but here's the thing it doesn't
change our home buying advice only buy a
house when you're ready whether the rate
is 2% or 7% or more buy a house when
you're ready here's what that means in
the ramay world you're debt-free you
have no Consumer Debt you have a full
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months expenses
and you have a solid down payment and uh
I only recommend the 15-year fix rate
mortgage which I know with current
interest rates you're like dude that's
going to blow up my payment well we
don't want you to be house poor and if
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay on a 15 years is going towards the
mortgage you're not going to have enough
money to you know do things like invest
for retirement and upgrade the car and
go on vacation and save for the kids
college and so that is the reason for
those parameters those guidelines and so
if you are are in that market you've
been waiting on the sidelines hoping
praying for the rates to take a dip uh
now is a good time to jump into the
market and work with a pro we call them
ramsy trusted real estate agents and
they're handpicked by our team they
actually care about you and your
financial goals and they they'll take
good care of you yeah absolutely so Ramy
solutions.com agents Ramy solutions.com
agents to get connected to one of those
Pros who will take great care of you and
uh listen it's going to be interesting
to see what happens over the next
quarter to two quarters in the housing
market well remember we did the real
estate reality check event and people
were freaking out that the whole Market
was going to crash and we kept telling
them it's not going to crash and here we
are today the market still has not
crashed in fact home values are going up
and the reason is is because inventory
is still very very low supply and demand
baby uh it's going to be interesting to
see how it shakes out as the Housing
Industry goes so goes the American
economy just a fun little if you look at
historical not headlines and all the
crap you see on Tik Tok and the gram I'm
telling you historically how the Housing
Industry goes is how the economy goes so
uh we're in this kind of an interesting
situation with the American economy as
it is with inflation still stubbornly
high even though it it's tend to
dropping a little bit still above what
the preferred rate of growth would be
which is about 2% inflation growth we're
still not seeing that and so it's still
squeezing Americans a lot we're seeing
uh credit card card debt all-time high
consumer confidence you know not great
starting to slow down a little bit so
what's going to give something's got to
we don't know but here's what we do know
uh people who follow the Ramy plan
aren't stressed out over the economy
they just not that worried about
interest rates when you don't have a
mortgage payment you're definitely not
worried about interest rates that is
true so let's get to the phones Stephen
is now joining us in Houston Texas
Stephen how can we
help hey guys uh thanks for taking my
call you bet what's up
hey so I went um I'm I'm a pretty new
listener to you guys and um I started
the baby steps um like a week ago we got
an emergency fund a $1,000 emergency
fund set and then we're on obviously
baby that too but I'm having trouble
with the budget we don't understand if
we're supposed to budget for unforeseen
things or if that's what the emergency
funds for and use every dollar just to
go towards that or how we work that sure
so give me an example of something that
would be unforeseen
seen U like maybe a car repair or or a
house repair I have a home warranty and
I don't know even know if that's a smart
move or not but something like that so
when it comes to baby step one $1,000
that's meant to cover these kind of
ankle biters that's why Dave you know
originally Dave's plan was get out of
debt and then he realized people would
fall off the wagon trying to get out of
debt because a $100 emergency would pop
up throwing them off the plan so that
thousand bucks is meant as just a
starter emergency fund and if something
happens let's say it's more than $11,000
what would you do realistically you're
going to pause those baby steps and
you're going to save up and you're going
to cash flow that expense and most of
these expenses aren't going to be much
more than a thousand bucks I mean the
chances of something crazy happening a
$5,000 emergency expense is a those are
going to be low chances in the next 18
months as you tackle your debt what's
your household
income uh we make 110 combined uh gross
so if you paused everything making 110
chances are you're going to be able to
cash flow an an emergency expense with
the next paycheck or
two yeah the yeah the thing is is I was
uh adding up all my credit card I have
$810 in minimum payments every month I
know that's killing us so uh we want to
pay this off but that's that's the
problem I was with do I do I take every
bit of extra money I have and put in
that basically bring countdown to zero
anything beyond your food shelter
utility Insurance all of that now when
we say zerob based budget what that
means is every dollar of income you have
coming in has a job it has an assignment
it doesn't mean you have zero dollars in
the bank so I would have a threshold in
your bank account for you it might be
300 bucks and we don't go under 300
dolls we budget down to 300 every
month okay okay yeah because the
budgeting program I use right now kind
of it's kind of weird with that but okay
I got you well let me hook you up with
every dollar have you tried that
out uh no I haven't I haven't tried that
one this is the only budgeting app you
need and uh a dimwit could use it and so
someone as smart as Steven can
definitely use it it's super easy to
navigate our team made it very consumer
friendly and I'm going to hook you up
with a year of the premium version so
you connect to your bank account track
transactions use the paycheck planning
tools that you know you're not going to
run out of money and hang on the line
Austin will pick up we'll gift that to
you if you're willing to use it Stephen
by the way there's no need to call me
names to make a point I look I I looked
at you when I said dimwit and I didn't
mean to I mean you did I thought I
thought it was more than a cutting
glance and I I'm a little sensitive I'm
trying to use 1950s insults these days
well you know I understand that but you
could have made your point without
taking a shot of it fair point I
apologize but he's right if I can use
it anyone can use it all right Amanda's
up next in Vancouver Amanda how can I
help hi thanks so much for taking my
call I have a bit of a different
question today um and it really ties
into what you guys your segment about
just talking about the interest rates my
question is should I buy my parents
house I am concerned about the interest
rates but it is my family's home um and
I'd like to be able to keep my parents
in it but I'm also afraid of mixing
family and
money what happened your parents wait a
second what is going
on uh well I live in a low cost of
living area I make a lot of money I have
no debt um I have a lot of extra income
I don't have a mortgage or anything my
parents live in an extremely high cost
of living area they've gotten themselves
into quite a pickle with some crippling
debt so I thought I could buy their
house and turn it around and rent it to
them it would be kind of a that
consolidation for them but also I have a
bit of savings maybe it'd be a good
investment for me because you know in
the Vancouver area the real estate
market it could be a good investment for
me anyways and kind of help them out
okay hold on so let's stop for a second
okay it could be it's not it could be it
either it is or it isn't if we if we
take Franklin Tennessee George and I
both know we both live in Frank we know
what neighborhoods would be an absolute
good investment so is that just the
wording you're using or you're not quite
sure if you were to even do this that
this is in fact a good investment for
you I think it would be a good
investment for me um my only concern is
yeah the interest rates are you know not
great right now but you don't know that
it's a good is this a good neighborhood
or not is this a great neighborhood good
neighborhood okay neighborhood what is
it it's a good neighborhood the house
was built in the ' 80s and it's a
family-friendly neighborhood okay I my
huge worry is that you are solving
nothing for them because their behavior
and choices what led them here and
they're going to continue to make those
choices even if you rent so I think they
need to accept the consequences of their
decision as growing adults and go rent
somewhere and rent something they can
afford and clean up this
mess I think the reality is with their
situation they would never be able to
afford to rent um but you can't handhold
them the rest of their life and that's
what's going to happen
here
there's no
endgame they need to change their
situation by making more spending less
getting out of debt and you can help
them do that with some tools and
resources but I would not step in as the
Savior here and try to do two birds one
stone investing in real estate and
trying to save my parents at the same
time they need to Grapple with the
decisions they've made even if it's a
good investment and she can afford it I
don't she's going to hold back her own
financial future renting at below market
rate to them I agree forever I agree
that's why I brought that up very good
she doesn't have money to buy her own
place feels like she might do it anyway
hope not this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the ramsy show where we
help you win with your money in your
work and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman and I'm joined by George camel
the phone number is
8825 5225 okay so how many of you out
there whether you've been listening to
us for a long time a little just a
little bit of time or you're brand new
realize that there's so much going on in
the financial World whether it's credit
cards uh buying stuff paying later uh
cars investing there's so much out there
where you feel like the game is stacked
against you and you're kind of like a
lot of anxiety going I feel like they
know more than I do and everybody's
doing this and I want to win with money
like think about your credit card
student loans car loans mortgages how
about all the different investing
strategies that are out there how about
the marketing mess messages and all the
things that are coming your way bye bye
bye bye bye and you're like I just want
to get out of the
Matrix if that's you I'm very excited to
tell you that my pal sitting right next
to me just got this during the break it
is the official hardback first copy of
his new book called Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress now let me just say this
okay listen Dave Ramsey's got the baby
steps book you know the the the The
Total Money Makeover then you got uh uh
uh the latest one which is you know the
the baby steps millionaire but this is a
very different book and I'm going to say
that it's very different in that you are
getting right into what I believe is the
Matrix that traps people from everything
from comparison to uh just messaging
that sounds like it's a good move you've
always been great at the traps um and
and what trips people up and and I want
you to know if if you're feeling broke
and and or you're scared to become broke
you're getting ready to adult this is
the book that will help you become a
millionaire just from simply not making
dumb decisions that let's be honest most
of us make I said us that means me and
George and even Dave Ramsey and so I
think this is a great book George and
that's my take on it as I look at the
chapters I mean here's what I want I
want to know what do you think the
reader is going to take from this if
they actually read this
it's one of those books where I want you
to read the whole thing and you walk
away just with this stupid grin on your
face because you go I know too much now
ignorance was Bliss and now I know too
much and not only that I'm confident in
my financial future for the first time
CU I've cut through all the noise of all
the ways I could invest and do I do this
do I get the house and how do I actually
live life without a credit score and I
walk people through how is how can we
turn wealth into just a game of patience
how do we walk through life with peace
and joy and margin and self-control
knowing that we're on track knowing that
we're not going to fall for these traps
anymore and it's the book you know I
wish I had yeah when I was in my 20s
it's a great book whether you're 25 or
55 because I write on a fifth grade
level cuz that's how my brain works so
I'm looking at it funny it's got a
couple scratch and sniff pages rled with
research there's 130 sources in there
that I really do deep Dives and enough
jokes that Ken might laugh you like the
new book smell don't you smells like
money that's what it smells like to me
smells like fresh dollar bills well you
know speaking of that Ken you mentioned
broke and you want people to be
millionaires this is my story in here as
well of how I went from broke to
millionaire the money mistakes I made
what I've learned in 10 years here at
ramsy and two first two-thirds of the
book are helping people understand how
this how this Matrix is stacked against
them how the system is designed to keep
them broke and then I show them a path
out so let's tell people when it comes
out it's on pre-order right now you can
order it now and get it when it comes
out give me the details so this book
Launches on the streets January 16 but
if you pre-order before then by January
15th it's 20 bucks for the hard cover
copy sent to you but we're going to also
include $100 worth of bonus items
including the ebook version the enhanced
audiobook version which I'm very excited
about the team's has some exciting
production elements we're adding to that
spicing it up an online Q&A event live
stream we're doing in January and for
anyone that buys a book before or after
we're going to give you three months of
every dollar premium on us fantastic so
that you can actually live out this even
your face has got a little snark on it
and expect we're going to have some
snark in the book as well and it's
bright bright orange this is going to
stand out in in the crowd Kev that's the
hope all right it's time we break free
from broke you get it ramsy
solutions.com
sstore get it for you get it for friends
and family this book is going to give
people a lot of hope I that's my prayer
for 2024 and one little bonus is that if
you are a small man you can see a great
outfit you can wear denim too so George
is doing it on the cover just a little
extra bonus this is just proof the
little man can get ahead in Amica
starts with me he can you have done it
two little men by the way I'm not much
bigger than you so thank you for making
that clear to America yeah yeah you know
people always ask how tall I am I think
what they're really asking is how short
is he yeah which is a very different
question that's I get that a lot from
people they they literally you know they
listen to you they hear you some of you
never see you those and they're always
like wow you're a lot shorter than I
thought you would be well thank you very
much heartful but just cuz I have a big
personality come on but I get that a lot
from people but it is what it is all
right let's get to Justin and West Palm
Beach florid oh boy wouldn't it be nice
to be in West Palm sipping on a lemonade
with Justin right now the Studio's going
to have to do Justin what's going on how
you guys doing well not as good as you
in West Palm but we're gonna we're gonna
press
through all right I think it should be
pretty simple but my wife's
transitioning into a stay-at-home mom
and once we clear out this debt the next
month I'm
wondering when we start investing the
15% take-home pay do we split it 7 and a
half% in my retirement and then seven
and a half in hers or because she's not
working do we not put to her
retirement great question so you guys
are in baby step two still yep and we
should be done by the end of the year
okay and then you got baby step three
the fully funded emergency fund to save
up for yep but we're talking mid 2024
you'll be starting to invest
15% yep y perfect yeah I just I'm an
accountant so I just think numbers so
you're thinking ahead I love it I'm
excited for you guys to start building
for that future and when is she gonna
stay
home uh it started this week oh wow oh
wow okay how old's the
child uh four and a half months oh my
goodness so exciting have you had a good
night's sleep in a
while uh no probably like a month ago it
feels like forever yeah yeah you'll get
through it trust me I feel that oh yeah
it's worth it George is on the same bus
you you're about a month ahead of us and
it's a lot but I'm excited for you guys
okay so financially are you guys still
on track to pay off debt aggressively
and you still got a great income yep yep
and I think with year and bonus it
should be all cleared out before the
first of the year so cool excellent so
you mentioned 15% that's going to be of
your gross income instead of your
take-home so what is your household
income going to be now that she's
staying at home uh
120,000 awesome and so if you start
doing the math 120 times that 0.15
that's going to turn into $188,000 a
year and so to make matters easier we'll
divide that but per month you're going
to do 1,500 bucks a month is what it
amounts to okay and so the way we look
at it is match beats Roth beats
traditional so if you have an employer
match we'll start there then you can
fully fund a Roth IRA and you do have
the option to fund a spousal Roth IRA
even if your spouse stays at
home okay so so that's something I would
encourage you to do depending on all of
your options but both of you having a
maxed out Roth IRA every year is a great
thing to do a great Habit to get into
okay so I split it between my retirement
and her retirement even though she's not
working right perfect so look at all of
your options and as part of that you may
end up funding her Roth IRA if you um
still have more Roth to go before you go
back to a traditional do you have a 401k
at work yes is there a Roth option
yep we've been doing Roth before we
started and stopped it currently so okay
yeah but that's I wouldn't worry about
splitting it 7 and a half and 7 and a
half I would focus on we need to invest
18,000 this year and we're going to
filter it through this match beats Roth
beats traditional and that could turn
into funding that Roth IRA every year
but way to go man gotcha thank you can I
throw one more thing on life insurance
we got 10 seconds go speed round do do
we do life insurance on her if she's not
working or no yes abolutely dude if
something happened to her God forbid you
need Mary Poppins it's going to cost you
150 Grand to hire 17 people so
absolutely get 10 to 12 times her income
that's probably going to be you know I'm
going to go let's say she would be
making 50 Grand I'd get 500,000 on her
today interestingly you mentioned Mary
poppet cuz I always got the idea that
she was free she just kind of flew in
one day and helped out well not in
today's economy I agree I agree wow good
stuff very serious stuff absolutely life
insurance is a must connect with our
friends at Xander they can help you it's
who we use they're great term life only
that's exactly right good stuff there
thanks for the call we'll talk soon
Justin hopefully hear some good stories
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campell joins me this
hour triple 8825 5225 is the phone
number to jump in our scripture of the
day is Hebrews 4:12 for the word of God
is alive and active sharper than any
double-edged sword it penetrates even to
dividing Soul and Spirit joint and
Marrow it judges the thoughts and
attitudes of the heart our quote from
Jack London you can't wait for
inspiration you have to go after it with
a
club I like that how about that it's
aggressive but it's good advice I like
that pound it you know just whack it's
like whack-a-mole get after it that's
another throwback there it is see I
can't can't help myself whack them all
and toll-f free calls that's what you
get you know what you could do you could
you could put in your own little time
phrases you know where's your stuff from
the from the 2000s I'm not that relevant
yeah I just don't think they said things
interestingly that's true that's we' got
a whole lot less stuck with this child a
society all right let's go to Greensboro
North Carolina Joshua is there Joshua
how can we
help hello George and Kim thank you for
so so much for your time and having me
on the show you bet what's up
um I guess I'll dive straight into my
question and um what are my next best
steps in my career to help me get
towards my dream job and I can give you
some background yeah tell me what the
dream job is give me the
background all right well I'll try to
keep it very brief because I know I'm on
time but I'll give you a quick
background you're doing great I discover
y I discovered Ramsey in my sophomore
year in high school through y''s High
School curriculum and fell in love with
y''s plan since when I've been through
FPU and continue to learn from Ramsey
Solutions books and various shows on the
Ramsey Network y have basically just
consumed my life and I've dedicated it
my life to share in y's plan of Hope
with everyone I can which led me to my
goal and Dre job I've had multiple
people tell me that I will never make it
but I've also had a lot of cheerleaders
in my life that encourage me that my
dream job is possible and I truly
believe through hard work my faith in
Jesus Christ and my passion for eny I
can obtain my dream job as a Ry
personality oh the dream job is the
ramsy personality he buried the lead I
didn't see that coming uh I did not see
it coming okay so your question is uh
what are the steps to take to try to do
the kind of thing that we do is that
right yes sir all right well um how
about we tag team this George sure I'll
I'll give one you give one and we see if
we run out of them that's great how does
that sound all right first I'm going to
start and I'm going to say the first
thing is is you're going to have to be
uh equal parts persistent that means
just getting after it try and try and
try and try and try and try and trying
putting in the work I mean like when no
one's looking you're doing the little
things you you are doing everything it
takes to be able to develop a voice to
speak with conviction uh to speak with
passion but to also speak with some
expertise and so you're going to have to
have equal parts
persistence and equal parts patience
that's where you got to start that's a
mindset at 17 I don't care if you're 17
27 37 you want to do what we do this is
not easy to get to the spot am I right
George I know our stories are very
similar so I start with that patience
persistence equal parts that's the
mindset getting going yeah and another
piece of this equation is you know I I
can't guarantee you anything in life I
didn't think I'd be here to be honest
with you Joshua on this side of the
microphone neither did I but you know
and it took and it for both Ken and I it
took a whole lot longer than we thought
it would and we would have liked it you
know this could be a decade Journey For
You yep and so it's going to be hard and
the good news is if it's what you're
called to do you're just going to get up
and do it anyways and you're going to
have that podcast even if four people
are listening and three of them are your
family and so you've got to want it that
badly but there's some tactical things I
want to tell you that you could start
with uh that will get you on that path
and number one is following the
principles so you're already doing that
it sounds like
correct yes sir so your life testimony
experience of going this is how I
experience life this is how I live Liv
my life debt-free starting at you know
17 years old this is how I lived it um
encouraging others along the way leading
Financial Peace University classes maybe
becoming a Ramy Financial coach going
through our training uh beginning to
develop a social media presence whatever
that looks like for you and you start
speaking at your churches and your local
community and you get any opportunity to
get on a stage and practice and and have
some at bats and it's going to be bad at
first and it'll probably stay bad for a
long time before you get any good at it
and that was my story Ken was a prodigy
probably since teenager but he had some
natural broadcasting skills that I
didn't have but I say that all to say
you got to just start doing it
regardless of Ramsay and so it's great
to have your eye on the prize but I want
you leading this and being a financial
coach and helping others whether it's
here or in your hometown yep um I'll
just add another one here that a lot of
people don't think about and that is you
got to figure out what your Unique Style
is so so you know if you look at the
great music artist you know they were
all inspired by somebody so you think
about the Beatles The Rolling Stones the
G Brooks think of some of the most
iconic artists out there they're all
influenced by other artists but they
while inspired by it they put their own
spin on it and I think it's really
crucial uh for anybody that wants to get
into this whatever you want to call this
space the content providing space
personality you know whatever influence
I hate that word uh but but I think
you've got to go what is my unique
offering as it relates to my style what
I'm good at doing George is good at
doing it one way maybe Ken's doing it uh
is good at doing it another way don't
forget that beyond the messaging and the
cuts at the plate at some point there's
something unique about you and you need
to settle into that and not try to be a
knockoff version of somebody else be
that unique version and I think that's
the advice I would give there is is that
with all of that you still got to SLE
down into this is how I'm wired and and
and last piece and this goes for and I
want to make this to the larger audience
if you're trying to start a
business um and you're looking for that
idea you're trying to start a podcast a
YouTube channel whatever make what moves
you so for authors that want to write I
always tell them write what you would
read uh if you're writing a song write
what you would sing because there's a
lot of people out there have the same
taste you have but but if you try to
figure out what everybody else is doing
and go over there you're going to be
really frustrated make what moves you
and and you're going to turn out you're
going to be okay and and that's the
journey but it is a long journey and I
love what you said George you got to try
a lot of stuff too like I I don't think
you can start soon enough to write to
speak to try to broadcast just try it
and just see where am I at on all this I
remember the first time I did radio I
showed up and my my pulse was through
the roof I bought my way on to a local
radio station in the Atlanta area and i'
had done a lot of speaking about on
stage before but this is a total
different ball game you got all this
stuff around you and the and the
producer's in my ear going 10 nine you
know and he's like you're live and the
light comes on it's just like you know
it was just an unbelievable pucker
moment and you got to learn how to
handle stuff like that you know it's a
lot of pressure under the spotlight how
does that hit you Joshua I'm curious oh
I think I put him on hold he's still
there oh he's there Joshua you there yes
sir does that help I really appreciate
yes sir I do have a second if time
allows I do have a second part to my
question all right real quick because we
got about a
minute all right um what can I do
because I unfortunately had to quit my
job last week due to illegal activity I
was calling mainly to see if there's
anything I can do right now me still
living at home so having more of like a
flexible um plan to work with since I
don't have that many expenses what's the
best option for me to do right now
career and job
to get experience well so if you're 17
and you just need an hourly job I would
be looking to work at a radio station
television station um you know if if you
work for a local uh organization where
there's writers involved and you're just
some type of get in the room is my point
um with with people that are doing what
we're doing I think that would be my
first step but you're 17 you got plenty
of time just go get a job that replaces
the job that you had and my goodness
illegal activity I want to ask more but
we don't have time but I'm glad you got
out of there Joshua that's the first hey
if you're working in a place where
there's illegal activity go ahead and
quit that's one red flag yikes probably
a lot more where that came from yeah wow
but great question when you think back
on it George it's uh it's crazy to think
where you can end up if you just stay
with it and you did that persistence is
key it was a nine-year journey for me
how long was it for you it was an 8-year
Journey for me I believe I had six jobs
here and uh here I am that's what I want
people to hear we've do we are very
blessed and Dave believed in us and gave
us a shot but I will say this we both
stuck with it and didn't quit and it
doesn't happen overnight and that's the
biggest myth out there the overnight
success that's right doesn't exist
George Campbell my good pal great show
today thank you James Charles our
fearless leader and all the guys in the
booth thank you thank you America and
our live studio audien is here today
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
la